[Música]
hora de hablar de los temas que a todos
nos competen en salud y para ello está
conmigo en el estudio madre romero sala
el día de hoy hablaremos de las opciones
de mar que tiene américa latina para
mejorar las campañas de inmunización de
la infancia así de angela muy buenos
días vamos a dejar un poco de lado las
vacunas contra el coi 19 para hablar de
otros tipos de vacunas particularmente
una vacuna que se llama hexavalente que
inmuniza contra 6 de enfermedades a lo
largo de varias dosis pero a la vez
entre ellas la polio tosferina difteria
por ejemplo y pues por ejemplo hay
panamá sido el primer país en incluir
todas estas dosis en sus campañas
nacionales y pues vamos a hablar de por
qué por ejemplo no se puede extender eso
a otros países de américa latina para
resolver todas estas cuestiones de
informarnos de más estamos con la
doctora marcela fama ya es
vicepresidente de la asociación
latinoamericana de pediatría doctora muy
buenos días cuéntenos se ha implementado
esta vacuna en panamá qué barreras hay
para que llegue a otros países de
américa latina colombia pero también el
resto
gracias mar muy buenos días bueno
realmente esta vacuna hexavalente
combinada tiene unas ventajas las
ventajas tuyas las enumera usted
contiene seis biológicos y
en una sola inyección pues podemos
cubrir contra todos esos biológicos se
podría optimizar la
la oportunidad en la vacunación aumentar
coberturas etcétera
ayudaría ayudaría de la inequidad en
vacunas
y pensamos que con esta nueva tecnología
se puede mejorar las coberturas y
y disminuir estas brechas de vacunación
generadas ahora y
posiblemente sea un tema más de costos
quizás pero podemos pensar que esta
vacuna va a generar un ahorro puede ser
revela es relevante también para el
gasto en salud porque incluye menos
almacenamiento menos jeringas menos
personal son unos costos indirectos que
están implícitos en la aplicación de una
vacuna combinada hexavalente además que
disminuiría la carga pues en los
sistemas sanitarios también entonces
pensamos que es una muy buena opción y
celebramos por esto la inclusión de
panamá en panamá de esta vacuna
hexavalente en su esquema de vacunación
bueno los refuerzos porque ellos ya
desde el 2014 la están aplicando en la
serie primaria de vacunación entonces
pensamos que si es un buen ejemplo a
seguir para los otros países de
latinoamérica
doctora marcela de buendía del ángela
gómez y le quisiera preguntar por la
situación en la región américa latina
aún es muy dependiente a la hora de
acceder a las vacunas cómo se puede
mirar un poco más es a esa dependencia
bueno es realmente a través del fondo
pro psc acceder a vacunas y los
programas ampliados de inmunizaciones en
nuestro país ex fuero en los países de
nuestra región pues realmente tienen
buen acceso a las vacunas pero hay
diferentes vacunas
y se están
involucrando o integrando de los planes
ampliado de inmunización de cada país y
si tenemos esquemas que son buenos que
son completos pero que se pueden seguir
mejorando y se pueden seguir mejorando
las tecnologías para lograr el efecto
deseado que cerrar estas brechas ahora
el en algunos países de latinoamérica
por ejemplo méxico también ya la tiene
incluida y chile que son ejemplos a
seguir lo que pasa es que panamá en este
momento ya también incluyó los refuerzos
y los dos refuerzos que se necesitan a
los 18 meses ya los 6 años entonces esa
es una ventaja doctora estaba hablando
de los costes también como una de las
posibles barreras a la hora de que todos
los países implementen estas vacunas en
ese sentido quería preguntarle qué papel
juegan también las farmacéuticas en ese
sentido es un debate que también se ha
planteado mucho a raíz de la pandemia de
kobe 19 que pueden hacer los fabricantes
bueno
aporta muchísimo porque aporta a la
elaboración de estos biológicos y hay
que hacer una articulación de esfuerzos
entonces cada uno juega un papel muy
importante las farmacéuticas en la
producción elaboración y en la
disponibilidad que haya de estas vacunas
para que los gobiernos los fondos de qom
para la vacunación todos estos se
articulen y se puedan adquirir esos
biológicos porque son maravillosos son
excelentes las vacunas son víctimas de
su propio éxito como digo yo por la
ventaja y por él
y el resultado tan maravilloso que
tienen en prevenir y en erradicar
enfermedades
entonces el que se beneficia de esto es
el que la recibe entonces si necesitamos
una articulación de todos de la empresa
pública la empresa privada del gobierno
de los sectores salud de los ministerios
de secretaría de salud etcétera para
poder adquirir esta vacuna y poder
llegar a quien la necesita que
finalmente es la persona que va a estar
protegida doctora pues muchas gracias
por todo su tiempo y esperamos también
que esta vacuna puede llegar cada vez a
más personas especialmente después de la
pandemia vemos que han disminuido esas
tasas de vacunación así que esperamos
que cada vez haya más países que la
tengan accesible para su población
muchas gracias y bueno la idea es seguir
cerrando brechas en vacunación y esta es
una magnífica oportunidad de hacerlo
muchas gracias y ahora yo soy la que le
da el agradecimiento a usted mar y
también a la doctora marcela fan por
haber estado con nosotros la tarea
difícil la que tenemos con la vacunación
y es momento de cambiar de tema vamos
con nuestro segundo invitado del día